In spite of all the flying dragons, Game of
Thrones is one of the most serious shows in
TV history.
And with all that tension on-screen, the show's
cast of award-winning actors from all over
the world simply has to break the tension
from time to time.
That results in some very charming — if
surprising — bloopers that will change the
way you watch these scenes in Game of Thrones.
Tyrion tongue twister
Peter Dinklage has won two Emmys and a Golden
Globe for his portrayal of Tyrion Lannister,
the witty, less-loved child of one of the
most powerful clans in Westeros.
Dinklage has excellent diction, honed over
a long career in front of cameras.
And yet certain words on certain days can
still escape him.
In this blooper, Dinklage can deliver a mouthful
of George R.R. Martin's invented names, but
he can't get a handle on a common English
word, no matter how hard he tries.
"The Wise Masters of Yunki and the benelovent…
and the benevelevoh.. haha!"
A watery grave
While offscreen and awaiting his fate for
being arrested for the murder of King Joffrey,
Tyrion has a serious question for his brother
Jaime Lannister.
"What's the punishment for regicide?
Drawing and quartering?"
Like any good brother, Jaime gives him the
brutal truth.
And apparently, that truth is enough to make
Tyrion lose control of his bladder.
"Drawing and quartering?"
"Beheading."
Hound vs. axe
In the sixth season of Game of Thrones, the
Hound, played by Rory McCann, has been taken
under the wing of Ian McShane's kind Brother
Ray.
In one scene, the Hound is hard at work chopping
wood while Brother Ray walks up to talk to
him.
The final cut has him effortlessly slicing
logs, but behind the scenes...it didn't go
so smoothly.
"I don't believe in your Seven."
Strong and silent
Esteemed British actor Charles Dance was well
cast as the mighty and imposing patriarch
Tywin Lannister.
As one of the finest actors of his generation,
he gives even the most dramatic scripts a
little something extra.
That's probably what people on the set thought
Dance was doing when he took a long, thoughtful
pause during a scene.
Was he acting?
Nope!
"Do I say something?
Is it me?
What?"
Wedding date
Maybe forgetting a line and making it look
like really good acting runs in the Lannister
family?
When Tywin asks his daughter, Cersei Lannister,
when her wedding will be, Cersei pauses for
some of that Lannister dramatic effect.
"When would the wedding take place, in your
mind?"
"I can't remember."
It seems that, like her on-screen dad, she
just happens to look super serious when she's
trying to think of her lines.
Lannister lingo
On the other side of the coin, actors are
just as liable to say too many words at one
time and deliver a bunch of gibberish.
In this blooper, it happened to Nikolaj Coster-Waldau.
When called out on violating a promise, Jaime
Lannister has the perfect excuse:
"I was trying to go back *mumbles*."
Burning back
Somebody almost got fired for this mistake
— literally.
While filming a scene as Oberyn Martell, actor
Pedro Pascal leaned against a wall … a little
too close to where a torch was burning.
Unlike a lot of other things on Game of Thrones,
that torch was not CGI — it was real fire,
and, as Pascal is reminded, fire is hot.
" (offscreen) Now that I am a matching --- "
Polite flub
In what's supposed to be a serious conversation
between Jaime Lannister and Brienne of Tarth,
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau is delivering his lines
normally...right up to the point he realizes
he's saying totally the wrong thing.
That flub doesn't make co-star Gwendoline
Christie break out into laughter.
What does is Coster-Waldau's genuine, heartfelt
apology for messing up the scene.
"Arya Stark hasn't been seen since her father
was killed.
What do you think happ --- no, that's not
what I'm saying, I'm sorry!"
Dance party
Tyrion's trial for the murder of Joffrey was
a serious moment in Season 4, but during their
entrance, Tyrion and Jaime just couldn't help
lightening the mood… with a full song and
dance number.
Their floor show continues all the way into
the courtroom, and two helmeted guards behind
Tyrion are even framed just like backup dancers.
Too bad Tyrion's case couldn't be decided
by a dance-off.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!